guten Morgen und herzlich willkommen
hier in der heeresbekleidungsanstalt in
Brunn am Gebirge mein Name ist Patricia
Scharrer und wir befinden uns hier in
der Offiziers und
unteroffiziersbekleidung und jetzt nehme
ich euch mit auf meinen Arbeitsplatz
also wir befinden uns hier im Büro von
der Offiziers und
unteroffiziersbekleidung ich habe 2017
bis 2019 meine Lehre als
betriebslogistikkauffrau hier begonnen
und offiziell jetzt seit Juli 2023 bin
ich hier lagermeisterin in diesem Objekt
hier sind wir für die Verwaltung der
vorteilungsgebühr verantwortlich hier
können die offizierung Unteroffiziere
als Berufssoldaten über den Webshop alle
Ausrüstungen von Unterwäsche bis zum
Kampfanzug mit der vorteilungsgebühr
käuflicher werden der Webshop ist über
das Internet abrufbar wo die einzelnen
Soldaten ihre Ausrüstung bestehen können
hier sind die einzelnen Soldaten auch
unterteilt über Fliegergruppe und
allgemein und zum Beispiel zeige ich
euch hier jetzt die Wollsocken die hier
im Webshop zum Beispiel käuflich zu
erwerben werden und wie eine Bestellung
bei uns abläuft und sobald Sie in
unserem System aufschlägt zeige ich euch
jetzt
so jetzt nehme ich euch mit nach hinten
wo meine Leute die einzelnen
Bestellungen für ganz Österreich
herrichten und verpacken wo man auch die
komplette
Lagerkapazität in ganz Österreich haben
also sobald die Bestellung ausgedruckt
worden ist kommt es nach hinten ins
Lager hier hat der Soldat Unterwäsche
Wollsocken sowie Handtücher bestellt und
beim kommissionieren mit dem
vollautomatischen Umlaufregal wird das
ganze dann kommissioniert
also die Bestellung ist jetzt
fertigkommissioniert und kommt jetzt zum
nächsten Schritt den verpacken
das Paket ist jetzt fertig verpackt und
kommt wie 140.000 weitere Pakete im Jahr
über Postweg zu ihrem Anforderungen
[Musik]